what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm waren Thompson
and it looks like we are about to get a
lot from Marvel Studios it actually
looks like we're going to be getting a
lot from Disney in general but of course
we love Marvel and through Disney's
plans we get all of our Marvel Studios
plans and the closer we get to the Super
Bowl the more it seems like the Deadpool
3 teaser trailer is confirmed for the
Super Bowl however we have heard some
reports about how exactly the trailer is
going to be shown what exactly we will
see during the Super Bowl and then after
which of course I'll explain in this
video it's also confirmed that Disney is
going to be present at cinemacon that is
this year and they are going to have
their own panel their own section and
it's not that far away it's April 11th
and it sounds like Disney but
specifically Marvel does have a lot to
announce so I know a lot of people are
wondering what exactly is coming is
Phase 6 coming possibly more trailers
will break down everything that you need
to know in this video so if you're new
be sure to subscribe to the channel hit
that notification Bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos we're
also doing a giveaway more on that at
the end so it does look like the
Deadpool 3 trailer is coming during the
Super Bowl and like I've mentioned
plenty of times by now this makes a lot
of sense a lot of people have been going
around stating online recently that
Deadpool 3 is going to save the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Deadpool 3 is going
to save Marvel and while I don't think
Marvel and the MCU is in that bad of
shape right now don't get me wrong it's
not the best by any means right now but
I don't think it's that bad however I do
agree with most of these statements I
think Deadpool 3 is going to knock it
out of the park and I think it's going
to be exactly what everyone needs at
this point in time both for the Diehard
Marvel fans like myself and probably you
watching this video and Casual fans as
well and simply fans who maybe not be
the biggest Marvel fans but they love
Deadpool and Hugh Jackman's Wolverine so
good news it looks like we are getting
the trailer but maybe not in the same
fashion that we would expect there's
going to be two different trailers one
is like a teaser of a teaser before the
real teaser the account on Twitter
Deadpool updates posted Deadpool 3 will
have a big game spot that will Air
during the Superbowl and then a
fulllength trailer that will be released
online shortly after now this is pretty
in line with what Marvel Studios usually
does they show us some clips or like
they mentioned a big game spot it has
some awesome footage maybe one scene
even and then at the end they say view
the full trailer online and I know
everybody's already asking so we go
ahead and just answer this typically
when they do this the trailer releases
online immediately typically as soon as
the Big Game Spot airs it is up on
YouTube right at the same time or right
away after that Big Game Spot is done
we're talking at the same time or like a
minute after they are usually really
really good about this so if you're a
big super bowl fan and you're going to
be watching the Super Bowl look out for
the Deadpool 3 Big Game Spot and if
you're not it'll appear on YouTube so if
you're monitoring Marvel Studios as
account make sure you have the
notifications turned on for them because
that's when you'll be notified for the
new Deadpool 3 teaser trailer and of
course have your notifications on for me
cuz I'll do the breakdown immediately
after and this report came from the
account Beyond reporter posted by
Deadpool updates now as far as what to
expect from the teaser trailer we
haven't really heard much about it in
fact we really haven't heard anything
about it at all besides what we just
mentioned in this video but keep one
thing in mind it is a teaser trailer
typically during teasers we don't find
out too much about the overall plot of
the film it's a teaser however for the
Deadpool trailers that we've typically
gotten in the past from Fox they do tell
us a decent amount about the film and
show us a decent amount as well and
Marvel Studios has been doing that
recently as well with their teaser
trailers we can expect this to probably
be around 2 minutes to 3 minutes long
I'm assuming it's going to be around 2
and 1/2 minutes I'm hoping we get a
fourth wall break from Deadpool and I
hope they talk about the Multiverse
because obviously Logan Wolverine died
in the movie Logan spoiler alert so fans
are kind of going to be wondering well
how is Wolverine back so hopefully they
talk about the Multiverse to explain
that or Deadpool breaks the fourth wall
and explains it in a really funny way so
be ready for the Deadpool 3 trailer it
is in 10 days and I really do hope it
Sparks excitement in the fans who
haven't been that excited about the MCU
lately and speaking of that Marvel studi
Disney like I mentioned is going to be
attending cinemacon this year and this
is actually probably where we're going
to get the full Deadpool trailer because
typically at cinemacon especially if we
refer to what Marvel did last year they
like to show footage and trailers for
their upcoming movies and the only movie
that we have coming out in 2024 is
Deadpool 3 so it seems like Disney and
Marvel have timed this pretty well we
get our first trailer for Deadpool 3 our
teaser during the Super Bowl then 2
months later we get a full trailer or we
get a scene shown from the movie that
has not been shown to us before last
year they did this with Guardians of the
Galaxy volume 3 and with the Marvels and
they showed a decent amount for
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3 they
showed the full clip of Star-Lord trying
to talk to Gamora on what he thought was
the private line but everybody else
could actually hear him and then they
all start to tell him well the colors
mean this the colors mean that they
showed that full scene and then they
showed a Sizzle reel for the rest of the
movie so again since Deadpool 3 is the
only film coming from Marvel Studios in
2024 we could probably expect to see
something of the same for Deadpool plus
not to mention at that point in time the
movie is going to only be about 3 months
away it comes out July 26 so this could
be where they really decide to ramp up
the promotions for Deadpool 3 starting
at cinemacon now since Deadpool is the
only movie coming out in 2024 we are
probably going to get a tease for Agatha
coven of chaos or darkle diaries as it's
been changed to and we've heard that the
title might even change again but who
knows at this point but at cinemacon
this is is probably where we are going
to get our first look of footage that is
at the Agatha Disney plus series Marvel
might actually decide to release the
first official trailer for Agatha during
cinemacon it's another great time to
release a trailer all eyes will be on
Disney and Marvel at that point in time
I mean we're a few months away from it
already and everybody is now talking
about Marvel Studios attending cinemacon
so Marvel Studios knows that and we'll
probably take that as the opportune
moment to release the trailer for coven
of chaos and another one is X-Men 96 now
X-Men 97 which still does not have a
release date yet like Agatha coven of
chaos is supposed to come out early 2024
and according to a recent report from
the cosmic circus.com that came out just
a few days ago they state that their
sources have told them that X-Men 97
season 1 will Premiere in mid to late
March so hopefully we get the teaser
trailer or the real trailer for that
pretty soon Marvel Studios might be
waiting for the Deadpool 3 trailer to
drop first before they start promoting
Xmen 97 because we already know that's
going to be huge and in 10 days but
hopefully this does remain true and this
will come out actually before cinemacon
last year Marvel Studios actually only
talked about two projects they talked
about Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3
and the Marvels they only showed clips
and trailers for those two particular
movies so perhaps Marvel Studios might
just keep their focus on Deadpool 3 and
the Agatha Disney Plus show however
there is a possibility that they might
give us a little look at Spider-Man
freshman year perhaps a sneak peek a
teaser trailer or a release date since
we don't have one for that either now
keep in mind Marvel Studios is attending
San Diego Comic-Con this year so when
people are asking about Phase 6 it's
most likely coming in San Diego ComicCon
cinemacon they don't have that long of a
panel and it's a Disney panel really
whereas at San Diego Comic Con we know
we have Marvel Hall h so for some clips
and possibly a full trailer for Deadpool
3 and Agatha darkle diaries that should
be coming at cinemacon plus not to
mention the Super Bowl trailer and then
for the big Phase 6 reveals those should
be coming at San Diego ComicCon this
year 2024 so lots of exciting things
happening let me know how excited you
are about the future of Marvel Studios
in the comments down below don't forget
to like this video And subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 an
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items as well the winner
picks one item and we pick one winner at
the end of each month you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof